President Trump and Jim Comey are
accusing each other of lying over
Spygate that's what Trump called reports
that the FBI had an informant in his
presidential campaign
call me tweeted today attacks on the FBI
and lying about its work will do lasting
damage to our country Trump responded by
suggesting that Comey
should worry about the upcoming IG
report if you look at what he did if you
look at all of the lies the tremendous
lies if you look at all that's going on
I think James Comey has got a lot of
problems now among those problems
according to a report from the Daily
Caller rank-and-file FBI agents now want
to testify to Congress that politics and
incompetence at the top are destroying
the bureau let's discuss that with
Senator Ron Johnson a chairman of the
Homeland Security Committee he recently
sent a letter to FBI director Chris Rea
requesting information on commis
briefing of Trump on that infamous
Russia dossiers and our great to have
you in the studio Lauren tell us what
what's what's going on here there are so
many different threads it is hard to
unpack let's try to keep it simple
there's a lot of smoke and you know
certainly what I'm trying to do is we're
trying to at the bottom of this but
Laura this is like a thousand-piece
jigsaw puzzle and Miller's probably got
a few hundred pieces i G Horowitz has a
few less because he doesn't have that
speed in power he can't bring in
witnesses from outside of government the
press has more pieces than members of
Congress because of all the leak well
they're getting a lot of leaks the left
precisely and people need to understand
you know what are what are those leakers
trying to accomplish they're trying to
get out of have the story before the
public has the truth but this entire
investigation is completely backwards
this is a political investigation I
think Congress ought to get the
information first write its reports then
if we see criminal activity refer that
to the Justice Department or Special
Counsel the problem with criminal
investigations it makes it very
difficult for Congress to get any
information whatever but we do have some
information and the way I'm trying to
lay it out is in timelines and you know
for example you know Chuck Grassley is
talking about the most recent tweet that
is getting some some prominence in on
August 5th the White House is running
this combine this with the tweet that we
got in a lot of trouble for publishing
let's put it up first what people say
this is a quote quote from Grassley to
Rosenstein today in a letter correct and
he said as one example of the text from
page and struck from lisa page and Peter
struck they want all those texts as one
example an officials name was redacted
in reference to a text about the Obama
White House running an investigation
although it is unclear to which
investigation they were referring going
back to my question the angle who knew
about this again we have summary
redactions we can't put all the pieces
together but there's again a lot of
smoke you combine that with the the
tweet that we published that I just got
bashed for in the press on a month later
September 2nd POTUS wants this is from
page 2 stress 2016 POTUS wants to know
everything we're doing now this is after
they've after they've closed up the
exonerated Hillary Clinton again that's
that's what we're gonna get an IG report
on soon again Horowitz did an excellent
job in McCabe you know got him caught
him lying and laid out 32 pages exactly
why the deputy and Acting Director of
the FBI lied to the FBI okay I mean if
anybody ought to know that's a crime
that's the man who should have done so
so no longer it's martyr martyr mccabe
and in these types of texts right here
are just unbelievably revealing the
question i asked in my opening angle who
basically knew how this was going down
carter page is the reason you're opening
up this big investigation well you're
you end up putting an informant out
there and then you end up surveilling
the Trump Tower and Kushner and all
these guys getting their phone calls
listened to and then yet this Russian
billionaire being visited by the FBI in
in August of Tor September of 2016 and
they try to get him to agree that this
is a collusion thing go and ice like
what are you talking about like they
were they were looking for I mean come
on help us with the collusion stuff and
even this Russian billionaire who hates
Paul Manafort Oleg Deripaska said I
can't stand them but this is ridiculous
it doesn't take much of imagination to
look at this and say this is a setup and
to get then again when you see the White
House is running this POTUS wants to
know everything we're doing
he's had to start putting two and two
together but again we maybe got 25 to 50
pieces out of that thousand page are you
good at doing jigsaw puzzles are you
good at yeah I I get a little frustrated
right now we are waiting for the IG
report on the Clinton email and
hopefully the Clinton Foundation that's
specially been our investigation in
three years we've been trying to get
this information so we'll get that but
we're where we are on the case I'm Ryan
do crisp array you know what is the
process for the document production
who's doing the redaction what's the
criteria what was it now we have John
Losh what is it now can't even get that
information so how do you do your
oversight it's it's not supposed to be
that it's this taffy plant oh there's
always a historic kind of tension among
the the branches of government no one
wants to be calculated people don't like
to you know show everything but I I
don't ever remember it being this bad
well I don't
what a surprise music we haven't had FBI
agents come forward to our committee
they'll go to the press well there go
and they want to testify on what senator
well come to well yeah we heard that
when Comey exonerated Clinton that they
actually wanted to you know they were
gonna blow a gasket basically why
haven't they come forward come forward
to my committee we'll protect you you
should also bring the Russian
billionaire in get him fun video get the
Russian lawyer get villus this guy is
she didn't come up they didn't talk to
her get a Deripaska be nice to have a
little bit more evidence before I start
doing those interviews but we may start
doing those interviews just to get the L
tell you a lot senator thank you for
coming in tonight thank you